♫
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THERE IS AN AWFUL LOT GOING
ON.
JUST MOMENTS AGO THE WHITE
HOUSE RELEASED A LETTER
SAYING THE PRESIDENT IS
INCLINED TO DECLASSIFY THAT
DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE MEMO
AND WILL WORK WITH THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE TO
SEE IF THEY CAN COME UP WITH
A RELEASABLE VERSION OF IT
MUCH REDACTED.
THAT IS NOT THE ONLY
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT.
THE RUSSIA STORY HAS
SUDDENLY BECOME AN FBI STORY
AND MOVING FASTER THAN
JUST A YEAR AGO ALL THE
SMARTS PEOPLE WERE MOCKING
DONALD TRUMP FOR BEING
INSANE ENOUGH TO SUGGEST THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SURVEILLED OR AS HE PUT IT
WIRETAPPED HIS CAMPAIGN.
WHAT A PARANOID LUNA
PARTICULAR THEY SAID GET OFF
TWITTER.
YEAH, WE NOW WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
THE QUESTION AT THIS POINT
IS HOW MANY PEOPLE IN
TRUMP’S ORBIT WEREN’T SPIED
ON BY THE FBI?
TRUMP ADVISOR CARTER PAGE
WAS PLACED UNDER GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLANCE IN THE FALL OF
2016 AFTER THE FEDS USED
UNCORROBORATED CLAIMS FROM
THE TRUMP DOSSIER TO JUSTIFY
A FISA WARRANT.
WE KNOW FROM CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY THAT PAGE SPOKE
WITH TRUMP ADVISOR, TRUMP
CAMPAIGN MANAGER STEVE
BANNON WHILE HE WAS BEING
SPIED ON.
MEANING THAT BANNON WAS
LIKELY SPIED ON, TOO.
TONIGHT, BASED ON OUR OWN
REPORTING, WE CAN TELL YOU
THAT CARTER PAGE ALSO SENT
EMAIL MESSAGES TO MEMBERS OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN DURING
THAT SAME PERIOD.
PRESUMABLY THE FBI
INTERCEPTED THOSE AS WELL.
SUDDENLY IT LOOKS LIKE THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION MAY
HAVE SPIED ON A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN TEAM.
JUST HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE
SURVEILLED AND TO WHAT
EXTENT?
HOW MUCH DID PRESIDENT OBAMA
KNOW ABOUT IT?
WE STILL TONIGHT HAVE THE
ANSWERS TO THOSE QUESTIONS.
THOUGH WE DEFINITELY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO THEM.
OH, NO, WE DON’T, SAY
DEMOCRATS.
ASKING QUESTIONS IS A SIGN
OF DISLOYALTY TO THIS
COUNTRY.
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO ONCE
TOLD US THAT SPYING
ABSOLUTELY NEVER HAPPENED
ARE NOW TELLING US THAT
SPYING WAS PERFECTLY
JUSTIFIED AND NORMAL.
WIFE?
BECAUSE RUSSIA.
OKAY.
BUFF THE FUNNY THING IS
ALMOST ALL OF THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION EVIDENCE UNEARTHED
RECENTLY IMPLICATES
DEMOCRATS.
NOT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
YESTERDAY WE LEARNED THAT,
FOR EXAMPLE, SENATOR MARK
WARNER OF VIRGINIA WAS
SECRETLY SENDING TEXT
MESSAGES TO A LOBBYIST FOR A
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH IN HOPE OF
MAKING CONTACT WITH THE
DOSSIER AUTHOR CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
WARNER TRIED TO HIDE THAT
CORRESPONDENCE.
I WOULD, QUOTE, NOT RATHER
HAVE A PAPER TRAIL HE TEXTED
THE OLIGARCH’S LOBBYISTS.
TRADITIONALLY IN WASHINGTON,
ANYWAY, NO PAPER TRAIL IS
NOT AN INDICATOR OF
TRANSPARENCY.
IN FACT, IT’S A SIGN OF
WRONGDOING.
NOW, WE ARE NOT SAYING THAT
SENATOR WARNER OUGHT TO
RESIGN HIS SEAT AND FACE
TREASON CHARGES AND WE ARE
NOT SAYING THAT BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT HYSTERICAL LIBERALS
WILLING TO POISON OUR
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS AND
MISUSE THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
JUST FOR CHEAP POLITICAL
ENDS.
WE DO THINK THAT WARNER’S
BEHAVIOR IS WORTH KNOWING
MORE ABOUT.
AND SO BY THE WAY A
REMARKABLE "NEW YORK TIMES"
STORY JUST PUBLISHED ABOUT
40 MINUTES AGO.
THAT STORY ALLEGES WITHIN
THE LAST YEAR AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES PAID A
SPY APPARENTLY A SPY WORKING
FOR THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
$100,000 IN AMERICAN TAKES
DOLLARS IN EXCHANGE FOR
UNVERIFIED AND POSSIBLY
FABRICATED INFORMATION ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW, WHY WOULD OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES USE
OUR MONEY TO DO SOMETHING
LIKE THAT?
WHY WOULD THEY DO ANYTHING
LIKE THAT UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES AND BY THE WAY
WHAT WAS THE INFORMATION
THEY GATHERED USED FOR?
NONE OF THAT IS CLEAR AT
THIS HOUR.
HERE’S WHAT IS CLEAR RIGHT
NOW.
THE BOTTOM LINE IN WHAT WE
LEARNED THIS WHOLE WEEK, THE
ONE THING WORTH TAKING AWAY
FROM A DRAMATIC WEEK IN
WASHINGTON IS THIS:  THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SPIED
ON A RIVAL POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
THERE HAD BETTER BE A
LEGITIMATE REASON FOR DOING
THAT INCREASINGLY IT LOOKS
LIKE THERE WASN’T.
FOX NEWS CHIEF NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT ED HENRY JOINS
US WITH MORE ON THAT RUSSIA
INTEL STORY.
ED?
>> TUCKER, THIS IS JUST
BREAKING THIS HOUR.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTING THAT A SHADOWY
RUSSIAN TRICKED AMERICAN SPY
OUT OF 100 GRAND LAST YEAR.
THEY PROMISED NOT JUST
INFORMATION ON DONALD TRUMP
BUT TO DELIVER STOLEN
NATIONAL SECURITY AGENCY
CYBER WEAPONS IN A DEAL THAT
THIS SHADOWY RUSSIAN
INSISTED WOULD ALSO INCLUDE,
YES, COMPROMISING MATERIAL
ON THE PRESIDENT.
SOUNDS LIKE A SPY KNOLL.
THE NSA HAS BEEN DEVASTATED
BY LOSING THE SECRET HACKING
TOOLINGS.
THEY DELIVERED THE CASH IN A
SUITCASE TO A BERLIN HOTEL
ROOM IN SEPTEMBER.
SUPPOSED TO BE THE FIRST
INSTALLMENT OF A
MILLION-DOLLAR PAYOUT.
HERE’S THE KICKER.
THE RUSSIAN CLAIMED THE
INFORMATION WOULD LINK THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS ASSOCIATES
TO RUSSIA.
BUT, INSTEAD OF PROVIDING
THE HACKING TOOLS, THE
RUSSIANS PRODUCED UNVERIFIED
AND POSSIBLY FABRICATED
INFORMATION INVOLVING
MR. TRUMP AND OTHERS.
BANK RECORDS, EMAILS,
PURPORTED RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE DATA.
SOUNDS A LITTLE BIT LIKE THE
STEELE DOSSIER.
SEVERAL U.S. INTEL OFFICIALS
TELL US TONIGHT THEY MADE
CLEAR THEY DID NOT WANT THE
TRUMP MATERIAL FROM THE
RUSSIANS.
THEY ARE INSISTING THEY HAVE
NEVER WANTED THIS.
HE WAS SUSPECTED OF HAVING
MURKY TIES INTO RUSSIAN
INTEL.
IT SOUNDS LIKE U.S. INTEL
OFFICIALS ARE SPINNING AFTER
THE FACT BECAUSE THEY WERE
IN NEGOTIATIONS.
THE NSA EVEN USED ITS
OFFICIAL TWITTER ACCOUNT
NEARLY A DOZEN TIMES TO SEND
OUT CODED MESSAGES TO THIS
RUSSIAN.
THE RUSSIANS EAGERNESS TO
SELL THE DIRT RAISED
SUSPICION ON AMERICAN SPIES
BECAUSE IT WAS PART OF AN
OPERATION TO FEED THE
INFORMATION OUT INTO THE
UNITED STATES INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AND PIT U.S. INTEL
OFFICIALS AGAINST MR. TRUMP.
IT WAS CONFUSING BECAUSE AT
ONE POINT THIS RUSSIAN
DROPPED HIS ASKING PRICE TO
$10 MILLION TO OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS.
THEN HE SHOWED A 15 SECOND
CLIP OF A VIDEO SHOWING A
MAN IN A ROOM TALKING TO TWO
WOMEN.
HE CLAIMED IT WAS MR. TRUMP.
BUT THERE WAS REALLY NO WAY
TO CONFIRM THAT IT WAS
MR. TRUMP WITH TWO WOMEN.
IT WAS A GRAINY VIDEO.
IT HAD NO AUDIO.
WE ARE TOLD THESE OFFICIALS
WERE SHOWN THE VIDEO IN THE
RUSSIAN EMBASSY IN BERLIN.
SO THIS SOUND LIKE A SPY
NOVEL.
AS YOU WERE JUST SAYING THE
PRESIDENT SOME TIME AGO WAS
SUGGESTING THAT SOME U.S.
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS WERE
OUTS TO GET HIM.
PEOPLE SAID THIS IS CRAZY.
THAT WOULDN’T HAPPEN.
BUT NOW THE "TIMES" IS
REPORTING TONIGHT A
REMARKABLE STORY SUGGESTING
THAT THEY WERE WILLING TO
PAY A MILLION DOLLARS TO
POTENTIALLY GET DIRT ON THE
PRESIDENT.
U.S. INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS.
THEY GAVE $100,000, THE
FIRST INSTALLMENT AND THE
SHADOWY RUSSIAN WENT AWAY
WITHOUT ANY DIRT ON THE
PRESIDENT.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: PRETTY I COULDN’T
KNOW BELIEVABLE.
SHOCKING.
VERY BADLY WRITTEN STORY.
LONG TIME ADVISOR TO HILLARY
CLINTON.
DEPUTY ASSISTANT UNDER OBAMA
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: I HAVE TO ASK YOU
TO THE EXTENT YOU KNOW ABOUT
THIS STORY THAT JUST BROKE
BUT THE LOT LINE IS OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY PAID
100,000 APPARENTLY A RUSSIAN
AGENT SALACIOUS INFORMATION
UNVERIFIED LIKELY FALSE
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT DOESN’T SEEM STANDARD.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK IT’S A COUPLE THINGS
WHILE IT DOES SOUND LIKE A
SPY NOVEL IT’S NONFICTION.
IT’S WHAT WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH.
I THINK THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES OFTEN HAVE TO PAY
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT GREAT TO
GET INFORMATION.
WE PAID $8 MILLION TO FIND
OUT WHO THE WORST SPY IN FBI
HISTORY WAS, ROBERT
HAPPENSON.
I THINK WE PAID $25 MILLION
TO LOCATE KHALID SHEIKH
MOHAMMED.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
I’M GLAD WE DID.
>> I’M GLAD, TOO.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF IT
WORKING BECAUSE I DON’T KNOW
WHEN.
YOU HAVEN’T HEARD ABOUT IT
THAT’S BECAUSE IT WAS
DEBUNKED EXACTLY AS ED WAS
SAYING.
>> Tucker: LOOK, THERE IS A
LOT WE DON’T KNOW AND I
DON’T WANT TO PRESUME
ANYTHING EVER.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS, OUR
GOVERNMENT PAID $100,000 OF
OUR MONEY TO BUY FAKE
SALACIOUS MATERIAL THAT THE
PRESIDENT, WHAT WOULD BE THE
NATIONAL SECURITY REASON FOR
DOING THAT?
>> I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT THE PRESIDENT’S
CAMPAIGN WAS STOCKED WITH
PEOPLE, STARTING WITH CARTER
PAGE, WHO, BY THE WAY, WAS
UNDER FBI SURVEILLANCE GOING
BACK TO 2013.
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S CAMPAIGN.
HIS CONTACTS WARRANTED
MULTIPLE SURVEILLANCE
WARRANTS, STARTING IN
OCTOBER OF 2016.
FOUR MORE TIMES AND MIND
YOU, DO THE MATH.
FOUR MORE TIMES TAKES YOU
INTO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: I’M AWARE OF THAT
YOU LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE ABANDONED CONCERNS
ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE
ASSUMING BECAUSE SOMEONE IS
UNDER SURVEILLANCE HE HAS
DONE SOMETHING WRONG WHEREAS
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE ONUS
IS ON THE GOVERNMENT TO
EXPLAIN WHY YOU ARE SPYING
ON AMERICANS.
>> I THINK MOST PEOPLE AGREE
WITH YOU.
I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOU
AND THE FISA COURT HAS A
VERY HIGH BAR.
>> Tucker: IT ACTUALLY
DOESN’T.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE ALMOST
NO APPLICATIONS FOR FISA
WARRANTS ARE TURNED DOWN.
>> VERY FEW EVER MADE
BECAUSE EVERYONE KNOWS.
>> Tucker: THIS IS THE
CHICKEN AND THE EGG.
THE TRUTH IS THEY ARE ALMOST
NEVER TURNED DOWN.
WE KNOW IN THIS CASE THE
DOSSIER WAS THE BACKBONE OF
THE REQUEST.
IT WAS THE FIRST THING IN
THE Q WE DO KNOW THAT AND A
WE KNOW THE DOSSIER BY THE
FBI’S OWN DESCRIPTION FLAKEY
DOCUMENT WHOSE CONTENTS THEY
COULD NOT VERIFY.
BOTTOM LINE DOES IT BOTHER
YOU.
>> IF I SAID DURING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT
THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION DURING
THE CAMPAIGN HAD SPIED ON
SPIED ON BOSTON OF MEMBERS
OBAMA CAMPAIGN TEAM.
>> THEY WERE SUSPECTED
RUSSIAN AGENTS.
>> Tucker: WHAT IF A YEAR
AND A HALF LATER THERE WAS
EVIDENCE THERE WERE NO
RUSSIAN AGENTS?
WOULD YOU SAY JEESH, BEFORE
YOU SPY ON A RIVAL POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN USING THE FBI, YOU
KNOW, YOU BETTER BE SURE
HAVE YOU GOT GOOD REASON.
>> INTERESTING ARGUMENT.
IS CARTER PAGE PART OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN OR NOT?
YOU MAKE IT SOUND LIKE HE
WAS THE RUNNING MATE, EXCEPT
WHEN IT COMES TO HIS
CONTACTS.
>> Tucker: HE DIDN’T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> IT’S NOT LOOKING AT THE
>> Tucker: NO, NO.
HERE’S THE POINT.
LOOK, CARTER PAGE, THIS SHOW
EXCLIEWNGELY LEARNED TODAY
EMAILED ABULBASHER OF IN
PEOPLE ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> IT’S CALLED SURVEILLANCE.
IF YOU ARE SURVEYING CARTER
PAGE WHO NEVER GOT PAID, HE
SAYS HE NEVER MET TRUMP.
TRUMP SAYS HE NEVER MET HIM.
WHATEVER, I WASN’T THERE
THAT’S WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT IT
I DON’T THINK HE WAS
INTEGRAL TO THE CAMPAIGN HE
HAD CONTACT WITH PEOPLE ON
THE CAMPAIGN.
ALL OF HIS CONVERSATIONS
BOTH WRITTEN AND VERBAL WERE
BEING SURVEILLED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> THAT’S WHAT SURVEILLANCE
IS.
THE TOE TAGHTS OF WHAT YOU
ARE DOING.
>> Tucker: THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IS SPYING ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> NO.
THEY ARE NOT.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
THANKFULLY TOOK THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
THEY WENT AND GOT A WARRANT
ON SOMEONE.
THE WARRANT WAS BASED ON
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
THE DOSSIER WAS PART OF THE
WARRANT.
THE WARRANT WAS PRIMARILY.
>> Tucker: THAT’S NOT TRUE.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
BUT THE POINT IS I’M JUST
SAYING.
LET’S BE TOTALLY HONEST
HERE.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, MAYBE THERE IS AN
AWESOME REASON FOR IT NO ONE
HAS EXPLAINED THAT YET.
BUT YOU ASSUME THAT IT’S
TOTALLY FINE.
YOU WOULD NOT ASSUME IT WAS
TOTALLY FINE IT WAS FLIPPED
AROUND, WOULD YOU.
>> I WOULD ASSUME -- I
HAPPEN TO TRUST OUR